[Music]
hi welcome everybody
for those of you who are joining us from
the twitch channel thanks for joining we
have another day of testing psychology
and I wanted to show some stuff about
caro-kann ways to play against Cara Khan
and hopefully next week I'll show how to
play against puke because we had some
they had this different
I had this different idea that I would
be showing different openings on how to
play against it and that's ideally what
I wanted to do when I started to
thinking about teaching this Jasmine
psychology because chess is not all
opening what opening is a very heavy
part on chest so yeah I had that idea
and so let's dive in I wanted to show
here today that's our cover time today I
showed some French previously and I
actually don't remember when it was but
it wasn't just on psychology series so
if you go on YouTube and look at the
other tips on psychology classes you
should be able to easily find it so
let's dive in so this specific game that
I'm showing was a game that I played
against sugar Shaw he he's an Indian
international master I don't think I
don't know if he has achieved his
Grandmaster title yet but he was
definitely working through it and so
they're one of my favorite things
because Abu Dhabi I played bhudev
International Festival many times I
played it in 22 13 14 15 and 16 and then
from 17 I had moved to us already so it
was really hard to try and play it so
yeah this was a very interesting game
because I was hunting down my woman
grandmaster in min international master
norms and so I really wanted to get
points from higher rate that's yeah okay
2015 I was a baby
good old times opinio teenager anyways I
had already achieved my woman
international master it was yeah 2015
was the year that I jumped so much in
racing in title but the next year the
same time I already had my titles and
rating was 2400 and good times anyways
so this is pure this is cork on defense
and I like to play this move 92 because
it kind of avoids the g6 ideas cuz
sometimes they play this 3-6 and I found
it easier so that my knight is here if
there would be some g6 played around I
always have the c3 to block out the
bishop but yeah so
so this is this was actually a
preparation that I kind of looked at
before the game and I am looking at the
chats but I'm I have it's kind of I
would have to manage the time because
I'm talking and looking so be patient
with me please but it will work out
great anyways so this Knight g5 was kind
of hot back in 2014-15 it's still very
very good move to play I think it's
still one of the best moves to play and
you I mean you have other options you
could just try to develop normally and
not follow the theory but this is I
really like this idea so yeah so
basically the idea is that I am going to
put as much as pressure as I can on your
the King and on your palms and the idea
is that let's say if you were to play h6
I wouldn't necessarily take it right now
I would just bring the Knights back and
for example if here you
if it was white to move again you could
think about bringing the other night out
and just putting more pressure and
castling and well yes if black were to
play wrong moves then yes as why she
would have the option to sacrifice the
night but my opponent was aware of the
traps and he didn't fall into them so
here after Queen takes
I feel very I felt very comfortable in
this position mainly because the your
queen is centralized and you're not
showing if you want to short caster a
long castle just yet all of your pieces
are in the right place and you're taking
away this short castle idea and at least
immediately so I absolutely like this
line for whites just because it's really
annoying for blacks to come up with
ideas anyways so this was another I
believe there are different ways to
approach this position I think nine f6
is one of the main moves and
another main move is Queen is Queen c7
and after Queen g4 King f8 because you
can't simply cancel because I just take
it six
so after King f8 I want you guys to take
a minute or two and think about what
would you do as whites I'm not looking
for a single move more as I'm looking
for a plan where do your pieces belong
so yeah I look I'll be looking in the
chat and seeing what's going on and we
have a background noise apparently
apparently there was a background yes
it's the server in the corner there's
nothing to be done we've had that server
sound in here for years that if we just
can't get it out of here
well I know that's a pretty pathetic
response but that's okay as long as
there's an explanation
oh we have a lot of fans from different
part of the world thank you
I'm still not getting any suggestions on
the chat on what you could do so just
let me know what you guys think I'd like
to make this lessons as interactive as
possible ideally its of just liked your
play clickers because we've been doing
this in chess and psychology so far and
it seems to be going good so
maybe give me some ideas on where do you
think I should cast though where do you
think the fish are gonna be so on c1
belongs
okay I'll give it another minute and if
I still don't have any any suggestions
on the chat I'll just move on but guys
give me suggestions you've been doing
suggestions and chats for for a very
long time now on the stream so
all right
okay so I'm getting good suggestions
sorry the chat wasn't actually
refreshing huh yeah that's a lot of good
suggestions all right so you guys I
think from what I'm seeing is that you
would like to do short Castille and you
would prefer to do something with c4 to
play d5 I think those were the
the big ones all right yeah so I went
with Schwartz castle in the game just
because the main idea that I had was if
I were to play like Bishop III and the
long castle the problem is that White's
pieces are kind of ready for the long
castle it would be very easy for blacks
to just play c5 b5 and try to create
some stuff in there and I really wanted
to avoid giving my opponent any sort of
counter play any sort of attack because
well he's he's a strong opponent and I
didn't want to feel trapped basically so
I did short castle
and so my idea was that I did want to
continue playing c4 and I did want to
try and fee on kids on my bishop so he
put the logical move of b6 because you
as black have to bring your bishop out
somehow and c4 so I had all of these my
preparations from this repertoire series
that's para marriage on Negi book had
and they were called like efore against
French
caro-kann and Pierre I talked about this
book before too and this was a very good
book for me it really helps me to
understand how to think and how to
understand what I'm trying to do against
French Perkin caro-kann at least he had
bunch of other series against Sicilian
too and I looked over those too but my
favorite one was dead French Pierre can
Carl come on so yeah these were mostly
his ideas that he put in his games in
his book so yeah
if you get bored and Quarantine maybe
check that out so the idea that I have
is to feel and get on my bishop so now
let's take a minute and think about what
would your opponent has black do so
think about what's the best move for
black
I'm looking at this with subtitles and
man I need to face my accent
there's subtitles on the video
apparently oh for chess it just doesn't
work
it's disregarded the horrible thing
about YouTube subtitles is you can't
teach it chess notation just doesn't
work true when I was saying caro-kann it
was like it was the funniest thing it
did get the French down so that was good
alright so I'm getting some suggestions
on c5 and yeah those are pretty cool
great thank you
so yeah the idea is that as black you
would want to play c5 now so think about
as white what would you do would you
take it with you play Bishop b2 will you
just let it be
I got my tea I'm kind of warming up now
yes yeah you're like a pot of tea
all right so we have suggestions on
pushing the pond so we have such as Suns
on d5
and we have Bishop b2 suggestions
oh we have 120 something viewers great
thank you people
all right so well I took it in the game
AB and I think hmm this should be too is
nice and if you take I would just
probably take back and it's a it's
comfortable I just wanted to be in
control of to take I wanted to take and
know where I'm placing my bishop first
now can someone tell me why Bishop b2 is
wrong
so now you're thinking why is Bishop b2
wrong and you're thinking it and I would
like to see a move suggestion from black
okay once more splash to move after
Bishop b2 and you're trying to I already
told you that Bishop Peter is not the
good move so just tell me why
all right so far I think I've seen one
person answer the correct one
I'll give it another few seconds before
I tell you guys dancer
so there are a lot of bishops Bishop
takes f3 Knight takes D 3 f6 and f5 I
think those are the four candidate moves
that you guys are suggesting I think
yes I'm getting some suggestions more
citizen stores f6 on f5 f5 is the better
move now if you want the the the way to
think about it is that this d3 Bishop is
already under attack and your Bishop g7
idea doesn't really work anymore so you
would have to relocate your Queen and
the question is where would you go
that's good enough that's protecting the
bishop for example so let's say you play
queen d4 first of all you have to think
about take and then you take and then
just rip t8 and everything for Black is
kind of already protected so black would
have an easier time basically and black
would have the two bishop and we would
ideally want to avoid that so that's why
after Knight takes e5 it's crucial to
play Bishop c2 first and after for
example and the next move you would want
to try and play Bishop beat you so after
for example a5 now you get to play
Bishop beat you now I'd like to take
another moment so that you guys can
absorb what's going on in the position
and maybe do a simple evaluation and I
would also like you guys to tell me if
you would want to be white or black
oh I got a question about why not Queen
takes g7 we're talking about here well
the problem is you take g7 the Queen
takes back and even if you take back
it's still you just gave up your piece a
little bit
so here I was hoping that you guys could
tell me if you want to be white or black
and after that suggest I move for a
black
all right so
so far I have suggestions that they want
to be white which is pretty cool
but move suggestion
all right so we have an e for
okay so most people prefer white which
is cool because of the king
alright it's understandable so let's
look at E for so the thing is when you
play E for I just relocate the night I
think 94 is also pretty viable because
now I might want to go to UPS to f5
it's what also thank you be pretty cool
if after E for you could just play 92
and I'm kind of
hold on wait wait wait
we haven't moved the Queen yet so wait
if a fork you can just take on g7 so
you're good there so the idea of efore
is good for those of you who suggested
it but you should first play h5 and
after the Queen moves then try for efore
like this potentially if the Queen were
to go to h3 then efore works but if the
Queen goes g3 the idea of Eve or still
would be wrong because of the weak g7
pun so sorry for the little hiccup there
so II for one more time if or it doesn't
work cause of g7 and that's why my
opponent played h5 first to see if my
queen were to go would go to h3 first h4
g-33 because those are the the Bible
places to go
yep
so
after age five where would you want to
propose your queen because you have
Queens if you have Queen g5 at five
you have so many places to go so let's
do a tiny poll and see where would you
like to place your queen
okay so someone so I have one suggestion
of queen g3 where else
okay so we have a variety of answers
nice well in the game I played Queen g3
just because I really wanted to keep the
pressure on boats
she said whoops both g7 and e5 so but
that's something that I did you don't
have to think like I do everybody thinks
differently that's I really like to put
pressure on my opponents so
okay so now after the if you were to
play clean for example h3e four could be
viable because now when you move the
knight for example I honestly don't
think it's a good idea but it's
something that you should think about
because if it works if you could play
for example III and try and use your two
bishops as black that would be very cool
but I don't think it's a good idea
because your king is not Castille than
your rooks are not doing anything
so that's regardless I would recommend
against in 4/4 black
so cringy 3 what do you think is the
best option for black they've already
talked about if we're not being a good
move because g7 is super weak and
they've already talked about if it was
my move again I would definitely take on
offense so what do you think black
should do
it's boxing move so oh I'm getting a
sticks I'm getting a rock age six and
Ricky eight
so I feel like those are the three top
suggestions
all right f6 is in fact the best move
because f6 kind of completely blinds
this bishop my B to Bishop and it's a
good idea to try and close up the
position as much as you can when your
opponent has advantage advantage as in
sense of space and King safety so yeah
epps accessorize f6 is the right move
thank you for all of those oh I'm
getting nice adjustments of Atlantis for
well my gosh where is a very good move
to think about but I don't think it's
ready just yet so that's why I played
drifty one if you were to play Knight h4
then e four is possible and so it's
better to play whoops
to play roof d1 to put more pressure on
the d6 Bishop and no now the e4 is not
possible anymore you can think about 9h
for so after up t8 so those of you who
suggested 9h for now we play Knight edge
for yeah the the g6 is where does wait
does get weak but let's see how it's
happened in the game
efore what would you do in this position
for white and don't just give me one one
one move give me a line okay so if I do
this opponent does this at least two
moves please so we can figure out
yeah I mean f6 is it's kind of icky to
look at but it's what the position
needed at that time
all right so I'm getting a trick t6
thank you
that's well first maybe think about
checks and then takes but you think I
think those should be your candidate
moves
yep my g6 is the my the move to play and
n96 is nice specifically because after
King g8 now please continue giving me
the wine because some of you suggested
this different ideas I really don't want
to say it but keep thinking about checks
and takes because this is a kind of nice
point in the position
all right yeah I'm getting good
suggestions
so if you take on these sticks first of
all you have to have calculated taking
with the Queen or taking with the rook
so please make sure you have calculated
that first and tell me what's what you
do if the opponent takes the truck and
then I tell me the line and then tell me
the line if the opponents were to take
with Queen
oops
sorry for the kick
you know nothing it's just trying to go
up in the strategic plan tactical
actually
all right so if work takes d6 we have a
suggestion
taking the rook
yes and after taking the rook I think my
initial idea the game was to play queen
g6 but rook t2 and my bishops are kind
of stuck and I would probably have to be
happy with perpetual so that's why it
makes more sense it was actually very
strong to play Bishop d1 first I'm still
attacking the h-pipe on and I still have
the idea of Queen g6 I just took my
bishop out of the fire way
all right so that's a last line again
this work takes t6 in the game he ope my
opponent to Queen d6 after an ID change
queen g3 taking with the H pawn because
taking with the either taking with the f
e would be three eventually we've become
really strong so it was I really wanted
to avoid that so now we are in this
situation please tell me what would you
like to do is White who do you want to
try and save the night save your bishops
and give me the other line please
it's okay I'm waiting for suggestions
okay so I have suggestions of route
c-141 I think both of them are viable
options and both of them are good to
think about perhaps truck
see one might be slightly more safe to
play
that's right
all right so let's look at your rook c1
I think that rook d1 is mine has a nice
idea behind it but the problem is that
even after this check you would have to
move this bishop and you kind of have to
voice a vote for example d4 and it just
doesn't feel like it's enough and I
really didn't want to risk it because I
really liked to have these two bishops
on I thought my position is good enough
not to have to make unnecessary risks so
Brooke c1 and I the one thing that I was
kind of worried about in the game was
III so we don't we have just a few moves
left so let's think about this if your
plant were to play III what would you do
as white
so with yes I'm getting the right
suggestions after E so after E is the
best move to play and the move that you
should think about the two moves that
you should think about for black re2 and
King takes h8
please give me lines for these two so we
can get back to the game
well I have 170 be yours 30 more of me
I really want to cross 200
I just hope that they capitalize on this
awesome number and stick around for
Grand Master yeah that would be very
great - yeah it's insane endgame isn't
it it is it's an endgame class yeah last
week I was watching a little bit of it
it was very strong
all right
okay so we are saying eat you losers
looking up - yes thank you for that line
what about King takes a shades what
would you do after King takes a shades
okay so I'm we're good with each if chin
takes a try - oh I really like the eye I
apologize in advance for the
pronunciation but saloon either a dream
you're right it contains h3 Bishop c3
I'm getting more of a ship see three
suggestions - so yeah the ship c3 is the
greates move to play and so basically if
eetu King f2 and everything is blocked
and I will win that a pawn in a matter
of Lube or - and if you were to take h8
I would play Bishop c3 knife rookie -
Bishop g6 is the key move because I'm
kind of keeping your king over there and
you give me two moves and I am coming
from mate so that's why III is a bad
move and my opponent correctly simply
just played King takes h8 I bought
Bishop c3 to kick the rook away and at
this point I realized that I my rook on
c1 is pretty useless so I decided to
exchange that off however my opponent
decided to try and keep pieces so I
think this will be our last question
because there are only few moves left so
just please tell me what would you do as
white in this position
the game did end in a draw because well
it was kind of hard for both of us to
crack the position but there were a lot
of a lot of positions and situations
that we both had to play very carefully
and for me it was pretty cool to keep my
position very solid and play have played
good enough to score draw it's
international master who was like 250
points more than me
yes King f1 is a good move but I think
there's something slightly more accurate
I'm pretty sure he will at some point
soon
the answer to max hiber
I'm really bad the pronunciations guys
yes so f3 was the move that I went for
because it's simply putting too much
pressure and I really enjoy just any
positions that you're just putting
pressure and putting pressure and
waiting for your opponent to crack it
just increases the chance of your
opponent making a mistake and that's
your lesson for psychology today I'm
kidding I'm all over this lesson but
that's the course of the day so anyways
after King g8 I had the option to play
King f1 and for example keep like this
and this hand game is extremely dry edge
because it's opposite colored bishops
and well there's not much that you can
do and opposite colored bishop even
though you would have a pawn up so
anyways back to the game let's wrap it
up I already took on d3 and then [ __ ]
f2 and here I I believe I think I opened
the drawer here for the drill and we
just accepted it because the next two
moves were for me would be king III and
taking on d3 and we were just simply
exchange works off the board and this
would be a position with opposite
colored bishops and game which is
dropped so thank you for your donation
mark Lopez I would like to say that for
next week hopefully we're all healthy
and still up and running so ideally the
plan is that next week I will show any
some game against caro-kann I've heerd
Bishop f5 because today we looked at 97
and Bishop f5 is another big line and
against Bishop f5 I play Knight g3
Bishop g6 and I really like this Knight
h3 idea or 92 it's not that's much
Theory heavy and it's really something
that you can even learn by looking at
few games and ideally I will show as
much as games as I can next week on this
and we'll keep following up with more
gains on caro-kann Pyrrhic and French
true ups this lovely quarantine
and yeah so my idea is that I'm going to
try and shift it a little bit more to
openings and try to focus on one opening
for a few weeks and then switch it to
another one so yeah hopefully you guys
enjoyed my class I hope all 180 - so
close to 200 of you will be around for
Darrow's Grand Master doors and game
class and yeah I will see you for ladies
night on Thursday
[Music]
you